nike jordan puma adidas the list goes on
all of these notable brands have some of
the biggest male athletes in the world
as the face of their products but let me
tell you about the black women who are
changing the game for these brands
let's take it back to the 1996 olympics
where her airness made sneaker history
cheryl swoops is a texas-born wnba
superstar and hall-of-famer who was the
first female basketball player to have
her own signature shoe swoops had not
one not two but seven nike signature
shoes she not only impacted the game but
also the sneaker and branding world for
black women athletes to come now 25
years following the air swoops debut
black women continue to carry the torch
and make their mark on the sneaker
industry speaking of carrying the torch
candace parker a two-time wnba champ
two-time mvp and full-time all-star
mother signed a multi-year deal with
adidas in 2008 in a time where signature
kicks aren't common in women's hoops
candace dropped the exhibit a's under
her ace collection cp3 continues to
dominate the league while lacing up with
kicks bearing her name and we all know
schuyler digging smith five-time wnba
all-star an olympic gold medalist but
her trends began way before her time in
the league as she rocked the head thai
style headband while starring at notre
dame which prompted nike to give sky her
own headband line fast forward to 2018
skyler has led puma hoop's comeback as
the first basketball player to sign with
the brand in 20 years now let's step off
the court and talk about a legit
trendsetter in 2017 ali may a south
central l.a born sneaker designer
stylist and international model became
the first woman to design a unisex
sneaker for the jordan brand which by
the way sold out in many and a second
woman ever to collaborate with the brand
in history since then she's had several
collaborations with the jordan brand in
2018 may told the undefeated we've
always been sneakerheads but we're
starting to get noticed and it's only
the beginning and let me tell you she
was right okay back to the court the
tennis courts that is four-time grand
slam champ naomi osaka a japanese
haitian woman has taken the tennis world
by storm back in 2019 she signed with
nike and since she's styled photographed
and curated for her three different
capsule collections that include
clothing and sneakers she continues to
represent women of color on and off the
board staying on the tennis courts we
have to acknowledge the 17 year old
phenom coco goth and when it comes to
brands she signed with new balance when
she was 14.
her collection was inspired by her love
for the 90s well thank you for
continuing to inspire the youth in the
2000s coco now y'all know we can't talk
about paying homage without mentioning
the williams sisters the sisters have
made tremendous feats in the fashion and
sneaker world venus signed a 40 million
dollar deal with reebok in 2000 which
was the largest endorsement deal of any
female athlete at the time her latest
partnership is with k swiss for her
activewear brand 11. as for serena she's
been with nike since 2003 and the
largest building at the brand's
headquarters is named after her without
the williams sisters the sports and
fashion world would not be the same and
y'all notice
these black women and so many others
have imprinted athletic brands with
empowerment and the beauty of color
[Music]